hey John how's it goin Oh me no I'm
doing alright I'm just you know chillin
with my peeps god this sweatshirt is
tight it's not even a sweatshirt it's a
frickin corset I got it at a gas station
in Kentucky and they only had mediums
and as we've learned from the Haiku
shirt I am NOT a medium oh that's better
I can't tell you how good it feels to be
swimming again in the ocean of large
Hank in the last few weeks I've actually
become the owner of quite a lot of peeps
related merchandise for instance there's
this puzzle it's a great puzzle but if I
might suggest one potential improvement
to the peeps corporation how about
instead of making the pieces out of
cardboard you make them out of peeps
also several weeks ago when I was in
South Carolina a nerdfighter gave me
these actual peeps now some people say
that you shouldn't eat peeps after
Easter because they might go bad but
Hank we're not talking about milk we're
talking about peeps the expiration date
on those peeps that nerdfighter gave me
several weeks ago November of 2009 and
now Hank although I know that peeps rot
you're already sensitive gut I am
challenging you to a peeps eating
contest with the winner to get some kind
of magnificent prize nerdfighters please
suggest what the winner and/or loser
should get in comments hank there are
only two rules three minutes of peeps
eating time no cheating
also since watching people eat peeps for
three minutes is really boring I'm gonna
intercut it with pictures of nerdfighter
awesomeness taken from the name okay I
can do this I can do this I can do this
I'm the greatest peeps eater of all time
I miss my years
before the crossbar but thank God step
one of the fine
get your shell like that girl stop we
welcome cows and mushroom on the bowels
and
yeah Bobby
Kodama cookie yahoo shades up tomorrow
and moms if I see gimmick mistake oh my
god semester
ah yes but it might not that they're
shutting every got there
guys up with an amendment
my dog is not as disappointed as I think
after your fight i'vegot say
ha
and mops if I see Tim McGraw
[Music]
I'm gone oh my god I feel awful about 30
seconds in I really almost had a
reversal of fortune but I held it down
I ate 12 peeps I four out of each of
these in three minutes meaning that I'm
actually half a peep less good at eating
peeps than I was a year ago oh Jesus
why did I do that I thought I was gonna
be so funny but just hurt I'm gonna go
lie down and try to let the beeps sugar
of course through my bloodstream until
things return to normal remember to tell
us in comments what should happen to the
winner in the loser